I am a mess and I miss Tyler so this
week Sofia and I are going to live like
we're single probably hang out my
sister's dog my dad my mom I'm gonna be
out of town on business and I'll be at
home with the cats
that's ScarJo and that's crusty chomping
away
crusty is my boyfriend I'm really
excited to get more time with my parents
we'll get the chance to really sit down
talk I absolutely love hiking with Sofia
but I also really love hiking my mom mom
say hi I am hoping that this week will
not turn me into a cat lady just a
single woman buying cat food officially
a cat lady now that I'm home I think I'm
redefining that term to me being you
know in LA I'm hoping to hang out with
some friends this week we connect with
that feeling of want to go out it's
Friday night and I was gonna go home
clean my house and do some laundry but
Freddie convinced me to go get a burrito
with her so
it's a linen was love you
burritos are for winners I'm really
excited to spend time with my family's
dog he is the perfect dog in so many
ways yeah hey boy I'm exhausted I don't
know I haven't been able to sleep
properly
Wow single I had so much fun to see I
haven't cleaned my room I haven't done
my dishes so that's all I am a mess I
have the room to sleep I don't want it I
miss Tyler when we decided to do this I
completely forgot that I had a stand-up
show this Saturday taking his step back
where I'm not with her not with her for
this week I realized you know I still
have a life that I really love Tyler is
the one who always comes to all my shows
we'll see if anyone comes when Tyler is
out of town it's only made better by
Sofia it's not like one of the other
don't think anyone is coming to see me
I don't miss being single so I'm gonna
take my notebook sit down somewhere try
and write a joke or do I think it's just
kind of you just confirm it I'm just
really happy with the relationship that
I'm in cardiac okay
thanks red see someone came besides
Tyler Tyler is coming back tomorrow I'm
really excited I'm like really really
pumped baby hi you miss me
I did all right it's okay yeah migas I
thought it lonely having my family like
that definitely helped fill someone at
the void but it was just a different
relationship I had to kind of just do
more I just had to be talking to people
I just think that we're blessed and like
I know that I have like sort of the
person that can be with the kick-butt
with that was like the sweetest thing
ever but I just I can't let go that you
just said that we're blessed you mess up
your lipstick ermine yeah you're good
that's on you it's pretty I like it it's
really caring yeah
[Music]